et personne sont assez touché de voir un
prêtre jeunes pour les gens qui sont non
chrétiens aussi parfois ils ont du mal à
comprendre je pense effectivement que
les prêtres sont des personnes avec des
cheveux gris pour les gens devenir
prêtre aujourd'hui en 2021 ça reste un
peu mystérieux bonjour je suis le père
etienne bienvenue dans cette église
bienheureux frédéric ozanam dans cette
ville de cergy où j'ai été deux années
en paroisse avant d'être ordonné prêtre
[Musique]
e
c'était
forcément un moment pour moi de grandes
émotions de grandes joies eelv et ma
famille mes amis et évidemment aussi
tous les prêtres du diocèse de pontoise
sur les prêtres du val d'oise qui
étaient là parce qu'il m'a cueilli comme
leurs frères
une ordination en fait c'est un rite
particulier au cours d'une messe c'est
la suite et l'accomplissement du
séminaire si on veut de mes formations
de ma formation de mes six années de
séminaire l'ordination c'est le début de
la vie en fait
[Musique]
et
j'ai fait des études dans une école
d'ingénieurs après le bac pour des
classes préparatoires donc à cergy et
c'est à cergy ici que j'ai eu le désir
un jour d'être prêtre alors j'ai
toujours été dans une famille chrétienne
j'ai toujours été chrétien j'ai toujours
aller à la messe le dimanche mais je ne
voulais pas du tout être prête j'ai
jamais pensé en fait quand j'étais dans
cette école d'ingénieurs à cergy je me
suis posé beaucoup de questions surtout
la question du sens de ma vie et donc un
jour c'était en début mars 2012
j'ai eu au fond de mon coeur
le désir d'être prêtre un désir
intérieure mais j'ai bien compris tout
de suite que c'était pas simplement mon
désir à moi mais c'est un désir qui
venait de quelqu'un d'autre s'ils
reculaient de dieu dieu avait posé en
moins ce désir d'être prêtre c'est assez
mystérieux j'ai jamais eu peur donc
jamais peur parce que je joue je savais
que c'est ce que dieu voulait et puis
surtout enfin je suis pas en connexion
directe comme ça avec dieu c'est ma
vocation aussi j'en ai parlé avec des
prêts de mes amis d'école d'ingénieurs
qui étaient croyants ou la plupart pas
croyant je crois que ça les a quand même
étonné pour les gens devenir prêtre
aujourd'hui en 2021
ça reste un peu mystérieux dans notre
société très connecté c'est vrai qu'on
peut très facilement évacuer dieu de
notre vie voilà parce que bon on est on
a toujours un écran sous les yeux je
prie tout seul dans mon dans l'oratoire
je ne suis pas dans un grand vide je ne
suis pas dans un grand silence mais en
fait je suis dans une relation vivante
alors bien sûr je n'entends pas des voix
je mens pas je ne m'entends pas dieu me
parler voilà je grandis aussi dans la
relation avec dieu en méditant la bible
en méditant les écritures et voilà comme
prête je suis appelé à prêcher à faire
des homélies à la messe a commenté la
parole de dieu
ça aussi ça me change intérieurement
[Musique]
pour un jeune prêtre tout est nouveau on
découvre tout la relation avec les
personnes aux relations de paternité en
fait on nous appelle mon père et ça
c'est très beau on n'est pas père par
des liens de sang mais par la foi et
puis on est là aussi pour désigner celui
qui est notre père dieu et personnes
sont assez touché de voir un prêtre
jeune et je crois que ça rassure aussi
beaucoup les chrétiens de se dire il ya
de la relève pour les gens qui sont non
chrétiens aussi parfois ils ont du mal à
comprendre ni place effectivement que
que les prêtres sont des personnes avec
des cheveux gris
à
en tout les années de séminaire là
j'étais souvent contactés au service des
jeunes de la paroisse donc et c'est là
qu'en france il ya les jeunes sont
confrontés à d'autres
d'autres jeunes de leur génération
qu'ils soient ne sont pas chrétiens ce
sont d'autres religions ce que j'ai vu
dans les paroisses où je suis passé
surtout les paroisses de banlieue
parisienne 20 de banlieue les passes de
banlieue dans la cour d'école dieu est
là aujourd'hui tellement d'athéisme
notre mission comme prêtre c'est aussi
de les former pour pouvoir pour qu'il
témoigne en fait de leur foi parce que
parfois ils n'osent pas parler de
assumer qu'ils sont chrétiens et en fait
on a une belle mission de devoir un peu
les armes et les les les affermir dans
leur foi en france une chute des
vocations pascal monde chrétien le
français vont sûrement un peu moins dans
les églises mais en tout cas ce qu'on
observe c'est clic avec même une soif de
spiritualité
chez les français il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui font de la méditation qui
j'ai rencontré récemment des personnes
non crédit non croyante qui veulent
partir dans une abbaye faire une
retraite qui est assez beau
à notre époque là dans une france qui
est moins chrétienne c'est que nos
manières de faire comme prêtre mais
aussi pour tous les chrétiens vont être
complètement différentes le
fonctionnement de la paroisse et puis je
crois qu'on va devoir plus à l'est sur
les routes murray samphan très agitée
dans la rue il ya c'est un livreur
hubrid ski qui m'arrêtent qui voulait
que je le bénis savent en avant avant
son travail parce qu'on appelle
l'évangélisation mais c'est à dire
parler de dieu à tous ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas et donc on va devoir
changer nos manières de faire dans
l'église et donc ça c'est super moi je
vais vous pouvez vivre ça comme croître
[Musique]
ce que je vois dans les différentes
paroisses je suis passé c'est que les
personnes le chrétien aime les belles du
rgi fond des choses qui élève l'âme en
notre génération de prêtres est
peut-être plus sensibles à ça et aussi
la génération des jeunes chrétiens sont
sensibles on revient par exemple on
retrouve des l'adoration du saint
sacrement par exemple on a besoin dans
un montré très connecté on a besoin de
sucre l'église et une identité assez
clair et et campus voilà l'église soit
au milieu du village
[Musique]